[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes le vendredi
23 décembre bienvenue dans ce dernier
numéro du 7-8 hebdo de l'année
voici l les titres il porte un gilet
violet sont dispatchés sur l'ensemble
des sites touristiques franciliens
pendant deux semaines les volontaires du
tourisme s'installe pour les fêtes de
fin d'année leur objectif et guider et
aider les visiteurs après une année 2016
difficile pour le secteur
le tourisme en ile de france il en sera
d'ailleurs question avec notre invité
fil rouge bruno myle yens vice-président
notamment du comité régional du tourisme
franciliens
nous évoquerons avec lui les différents
moyens dont dispose la région pour
relancer la machine touristes et puis
enfin dans le reste de l'actualité
nous reviendrons sur les événements
forts qui ont marqué l'année 2016
il sera également question du père noël
dans cet hebdo ce dernier raid d'eau de
l'année attentats manifestation
inondations l'année 2016 a été marquée
par de tristes événements en
ile-de-france principales victimes de
cette série noire
le secteur du tourisme et pour inverser
la tendance la région a lancé un plan de
relance parmi les outils déployés les
volontaires du tourisme 200 personnes
qui dit des aides les touristes dont
leur escapade comme à versailles durant
les fêtes de noël
reportage
[Musique]
si une its de nexway à la gare de
versailles hermance est en contact toute
la journée avec des touristes du monde
entier
étudiante en deuxième année de bts
tourisme son rôle et simples mais
essentielles répondre aux nombreuses
interrogations que peuvent se poser les
visiteurs étrangers ou français à
certaines questions de vue que c'est pas
le je connais pas énormément la région
c'est surtout ça qui est compliqué mais
on apprend sur le tas y au fil des jours
on commence à connaître les questions se
répète donc on a eu une mauvaise
expérience en venant ici on a acheté le
mauvais ticket et la police les a mis
une amende
maintenant elle je la remercie elle fait
du bon boulot oui oui elle nous est
vraiment mais elle n'a pas encore fini
en tout 200 gilets violets sillonnent
les principaux sites franciliens pendant
les fêtes de noël une approche pour
tenter de séduire à nouveau les
visiteurs après les événements tragiques
de ces derniers mois en 2016 la région a
perdu près d'un milliard et demi d'euros
de recettes touristiques s'agit pas
uniquement de les orienter
mais aussi de leur dire que paris et
d'ile-de-france regard regorge de mille
richesses et qu'on est aussi capable de
les emmener faire un bateau un tour de
bateau sur la seine
un cabaret une croisière ce genre de
choses dont les yvelines les volontaires
du tourisme sont également déployés
devant le château de versailles
l'opération si elle s'avère efficace
sera amplifié l'an prochain on va
continuer à développer cette thématique
du tourisme avec notre invité fil rouge
brune au millième bonsoir bonsoir
alors vous êtes notamment conseiller
régional d'île de france président du
modem 78 et puis je le disais vice
président du crt le comité régional du
tourisme
c'est le crt d'ailleurs qui est en
charge des volontaires du tourisme
on a vu dans le reportage que c'est une
bonne action tout le monde s'entend
là-dessus mais on a un peu du mal à
croire que c'est de son stagiaire aussi
bon soit-il qui vont inverser la
tendance du tourisme en ile de france
puisque c'est après cela elle est un peu
faussée ou alors vous y croyez vous non
ce qui est important ce qu'il fallait
qu'on fasse revenir effectivement sur
les sites touristiques des gens qui soit
en capacité de guider nos touristes
parce que ça c'est un vrai problème
parce qu'il ya des barrières de la
langue parce que les gens ne connaissent
pas forcément tous les fonctionnements
c'est un petit peu compliqué donc mettre
en place ces gens là qui sont dès qu'ils
sont des étudiants et des stagiaires
étudiants qui viennent
dans les moments où il ya une forte
affluence touristique au moment des
vacances landais sur noël mais ça sera
pareil l'été prochain ça ça peut être un
vrai plus parce que jusqu'à maintenant
les touristes étaient un petit peu
perdues même dans la capitale c'est un
petit peu compliqué de se repérer dedans
donc ça c'est important mais on ne fait
pas que ça bien évidemment on a on a
réattaqué effectivement nos nos contacts
notamment asiatiques parce qu'on avait
perdu pas mal de clientèle asiatique à
cause des attentats notamment des
attentats les intempéries les attentats
plus les grèves à une série noire un
jeune noah a été catastrophique donc
donc là on repart à la reconquête de
tous de tous ces gens là des agences de
voyages des tours opérateurs pour faire
revenir les gens sur paris en ile de
france
est ce que l'idée aussi de ces
volontaires de tourisme c'est de casser
un peu l'image bon la france est un joli
pays on le sait mais les français sont
pas forcément les gens les plus
chaleureux envers les touristes score on
a une image qui nous colle à la peau
est-ce que c'est aussi ça l'idée des
volontaires du touriste est pas qu une
image j'ai bien l'impression c'est à
dire que effectivement les touristes
peuvent bien tomber quand il demande un
renseignement dans la rue mais peuvent
aussi très mal tomber le parisien on le
sait et même le francilien on va écarter
je veux pas faire de l'anti parisianisme
primaire mais on est des fois pas très
aimable avec les gens qui nous demandent
des renseignements qu'ils soient
touristes ou pas d'ailleurs donc c'est
bien pour eux d'avoir un pôle vers
lequel ils peuvent se diriger ils savent
exactement à qui s'adresser et à partir
de ce moment-là il sait qu'ils auront
exactement les renseignements qui
demander votre reportage les lustres
c'est pas seulement ils viennent à au
château de versailles pour visiter le
château de versailles
mais on va leur proposer autre chose que
le château de versailles en plus du
château de versailles
donc ça élargit aussi le spectre de tout
ce qu'ils peuvent faire enfin à paris en
ile de france alors il peut pour évoquer
cette crise du tourisme
rappelons les grands chiffres du secteur
en ile-de-france pour pour 2016 pertes
environs d'un milliard et demi d'euros à
la fin du mois d'octobre baisse des
réservations aussi dans les hôtels à peu
près 10% sur sur la grande région on est
à un chiffre un peu plus faible oui sur
la grande région soit grande couronne on
est à 5 - 5 2 donc voilà sur l'île de
france on est à moi cette cime
préservation des terres dans les hôtels
est ce que c'est possible à court terme
d'inverser cette tendance ou alors ça va
prendre des années
avec ça va prendre du temps là on a
quand même quelque chose qui est
encourageant c'est que
le nombre d'arrivées touristes en tout
cas enregistre une hausse cette année on
passe de 3,5 à 4,5 mais malgré tout on a
moins de nuitées mais ça il va falloir
qu'on travaille effectivement ça ne
ça ne s'efface pas ce qu'on a vécu là en
ça ne s'efface pas comme ça d'un trait
d'un coup le problème numéro un c'est
est ce que c'est le sentiment de
sécurité finalement est ce que c'est ça
la priorité est ce qu'il faut a axé
là-dessus avant le sentiment qu'à paris
et dans sa région on est en sécurité
quand on est là à dia tic lebrun
américain le paradoxe c'est que nous on
a soulevé sa dans tout l'est dans tous
les conseils d'administration qu'on a eu
cette année les retours qu'on a des gens
du tourisme ne disent que c'est une
catastrophe pour eux d'avoir une image
de paris et d'ile-de-france qui est sous
état d'urgence
alors il faut il faut il a été prolongée
qui a été prolongé récemment il faut
qu'on y soit mais c'est le terme état
d'urgence qui fait qui fait pas sexy
cologix et psychologique voilà comment
la région peut jouer sur ce levier de la
sécurité valérie pécresse a lancé veut
mettre en place l'an prochain des
commissariats mobile et c'est quoi des
commissariats on allait commissariat
mobile vous imaginez bien quelqu'un qui
arrive puisque on n'est pas loin de
versailles quelqu'un qui arrive à
versailles et qui a malheureusement
affaire à un pickpocket et qui s'en
aperçoit vous imaginez que la complexité
pour l'étranger d'aller au commissariat
porter plainte tombe et peut-être sur
des gens qui possèdent pas la langue et
c'est donc le commissariat mobile c'est
ça c'est d'avoir un point où ils peuvent
peut aller s'ils ont un problème
directement tout de suite à proximité du
lieu touristique pour pouvoir faire
toutes les démarches nécessaires
dernières réflexions sur cette
thématique du tourisme vous qui êtes
aussi un élu de territoire rural puisque
vous êtes élu municipal à jumeaux ville
est-ce que développer le tourisme en
zone rurale c'est une réflexion qu'on
peut mener aussi pour revigorer le
secteur touristique on est si oui
comment donc en train de l'amener ça ça
va prendre du temps en revanche pas ce
que vous voyez bien qu'on a un problème
entre paris intra muros qui déjà on peut
penser que paris n'a pas suffisamment de
chambres disponibles pour l'ensemble des
touristes
la petite couronne en a de plus en plus
nous en terme d'hébergement sur la
grande couronne
c'est plus compliqué d'agde d'abord il
faut qu'on prend force ça et après ils
font un territoire aussi un grand oui
oui mais je vais on remplace dans les
zones rurales tout ce qui est des berges
mans mais on a beaucoup d'hébergement de
gîtes de trucs comme ça mais il faut
qu'on ait toute la palette de
l'hébergement si vous venez à versailles
pour le château de versailles les gens
qui ont beaucoup d'argent ils ont je
vais pas citer de nom d'hôtel mais ils
ont grosso modo 1 vers lequel ils
veulent aller est souvent plein donc
voilà ils ont pas forcément de
possibilité d'aller ailleurs donc qui
retourne à paris après avoir visité le
château de versailles donc il faut qu'on
renforce l'hébergement il faut qu'on
offre d'autres possibilités touristiques
là on l'a fait avec la marque sais pas
si vous avez vu destination
impressionnisme qui est en train de se
mettre en marche dans les yvelines
bah pas que dans les yvelines puisque
c'est un accord entre la région ile de
france et la région normandie donc on va
raser voilà ça passe par les yvelines on
va retracer le parcours des
impressionnistes depuis paris jusqu'à
honfleur dieppe et c'est pour développer
là ça sera un formidable
comment dire une formidable voie
d'accélération pour les territoires pour
se développer touristiquement de
capitaliser autour de ce que les
impressionnistes ont fait dans leur
droit bruno myle yens rester avec nous
on passe à l'actualité de la semaine
l'actualité de la semaine voire de
l'année tous les jours la rédaction de
tv fils vous a proposé une rétrospective
des sujets qui ont marqué l'année 2016
la politique a bien sûr très souvent
trusté la une de nos journaux
retour sur cette année politique avec
wilfrid richie l'année politique débute
en janvier par la tenue du premier
conseil communautaire d'un saint quentin
en yvelines dorénavant composé de douze
communes au revoir la casse qui est
bonjour à sky
michel laugier maire divers droite de
montigny le bretonneux conserve la
présidence
ces nouvelles aventures parce que c'est
déjà un nouveau territoire c'est un
nouveau territoire avec d'autres enjeux
regardez tout simplement aujourd'hui de
là nous avions trois gars sur le
territoire nous adorons cette nous avons
c'est désormais une nouvelle aventure
qui débute mal avec une opposition de
gauche qui refuse de prendre part aux
premiers votes s'estimant exclus de la
gouvernance les tensions se poursuivront
tout au long de l'année
la détention également entre le
département des yvelines et l'état les
élus du conseil départemental engage un
bras de fer avec le gouvernement
suite à la diminution des dotations
versées une diminution de 288 millions
d'euros en septembre une manifestation
avait lieu devant l'assemblée nationale
ce sont des sommes absolument
considérable que l'état ne nous donne
plus alors qu'il décide de nos dépenses
les dépenses sociales et ils ne
compensent pas alors que normalement il
a cette obligation constitutionnelle
face à des ressources en chute les
yvelines tente de se rapprocher des
hauts de seine pour mutualiser les
moyens en juin un premier budget commun
était votée 2017 sera une année
électorale chargée entre présidentielle
sénatoriales et législatives et les
différentes campagnes ont débuté dès
cette année la primaire de la droite et
du centre a vu la victoire de françois
fillon et françois fillon largement en
tête également dans les yvelines avec +2
66% à de la primaire on retiendra
également la candidature du député
yvelinois président du parti chrétien
démocrate jean frédéric poisson
inconnu du grand public il a marqué les
débats avec des prises de positions sur
plusieurs sujets de société et c'est
pendant cette primaire à droite que
c'est préparer la primaire de la gauche
verdict en janvier 2010 est un livre les
noix et là aussi en course benoît hamon
députés socialistes
en campagne il poursuit sa critique du
gouvernement qu'il a quitté en 2014
enfin 2016 aura été marqué sur saint
quentin en yvelines par deux départs de
mer en mars c'était un lynchage qui pour
des raisons de santé laisser nelly duthu
prendre la tête de l'une des dernières
villes communistes d'île de france
comme toujours dans ce moment là on
espère que les choses vont s'améliorer
s'arranger c'est pas tout à fait le kg
la situation de santé encore besoin
d'attention de soins en octobre françois
de ligne et maire ps de guyancourt
depuis quatorze ans passés lui la main à
marie christine le tarnec
une décision qu'il dit avoir prise afin
de préparer l'avenir
bruno myle yen on l'a vu l'année 2016 a
été chargée en termes d'actualité
politique 2010 et devait être encore
plus chargé on aura l'occasion de
revenir dessus mais parlons d'abord des
sujets plus locaux
quel regard vous portez vous en tant
qu'élu municipal élu régional sur le
rapprochement entre les yvelines et les
hauts-de-seine vous qui êtes rang entre
les deux on va dire à l'échelon
inférieur à l'échelon supérieur
selon vous c'est un rapprochement qui
est souhaitable qui est nuisible pour
l'instant j'en mesure pas complètement
l'utilité et l'efficacité si c'est une
mutualisation des moyens je veux bien
comprendre parce qu'effectivement on a
besoin d'économiser des sous partout on
sait que notation globale que donne
l'état au département a considérablement
baissé
et c'est pas complètement idiot de
fusionner les deux en termes de moyens
après je voudrais savoir exactement ce
qu'on va en faire
première chose et deuxième chose quel va
être l'avenir des départements notamment
dans la région ile de france parce que
le serpent de mer revient c'est la
question que j'allais vous poser est ce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas c'est pas le
moment de dire qu'il ya une collectivité
en trop au sein de l'ile-de-france et si
oui laquelle selon vous est ce que c'est
le grand paris est ce que c'est la
région est ce que c'est le département
est ce que c'est les intercoms est ce
que c'est la ville moi je n'ai pas
l'habitude d'avoir la langue de bois
déjà je vous dis la métropole du grand
paris c'est clair ça ne sert à rien
voilà ce en partie pour ça que les deux
départements se rapproche aussi c'est ça
le sert strictement à la métropole du
grand paris n'a de sens que si elle est
l'échelon de la région
d'accord là je pense que même si on fait
pas partie de la même famille politique
avec valérie pécresse mais tout à fait
d'accord là-dessus l'échelon communal
il est ultra important alors évidemment
on pousse les communes soient fusionnées
soit rentré dans un des intercommunales
regardez celui ci mais faut le garder
cette et chemins c'est celui qui est le
plus proche des gens c'est ce que m'ont
dit il comme disent les mères c'est
l'échelon on a apporté d'engueulades
mais ils ont raison on en a besoin parce
que ça c'est les remontées qu'on les
échelons au-dessus s'élèverait remontée
que les échanges et les départements
vous dites ça les départements
aujourd'hui ou alors il faut redéfinir
les rôles je sais pas mais il ya quand
même il ya un problème je pense que
l'idée du conseiller territorial qui
avait été
lancé par nicolas sarkozy mais qui
n'avait pas abouti peut-être faudrait y
réfléchir nous on va parler maintenant
de sujets plus nationaux et 2016 a été
marquée on l'a vu un pas la primaire de
la droite et du centre le modem votre
parti à vous puisque vous êtes président
du modem ce sont 18 soutenait
ouvertement alain juppé alain juppé qui
a perdu face à françois fillon françois
fillon excusez moi et depuis on se pose
la question est ce que françois bayrou
le président du modem va se présenter et
lui à l'élection présidentielle il fait
durer le suspense est ce que vous avez
vous des informations à nous donner ce
soir
alors non avant la première je ne
reproche pas plus d'infos à vous donner
déjà la chose importante qu'il faut
savoir c'est que les deux françois se
parle ça c'est important
ils ont de l'estimé l'un pour l'autre
donc ils discutent tous les deux ils
discutent plutôt de manière amicale ce a
déjà tant qu'on est dans le dialogue et
la discussion
on peut voir aboutir des choses nous ce
qui nous a gênés sur le sur l'élection
sur le projet de françois fillon a bien
compris que le projet de françois fillon
était un projet pour gagner les
primaires lui il a fait un projet pour
gagner les primaires en tapant là où
c'est le jeu veut pas dire la droite
dure messaoud où c'est le plus à droite
alors qu'alain juppé avait fait un
projet présidentiel plus rassembleur il
va falloir que le projet de françois
fillon devient un tout petit peu plus
rassembleur voix s'il n'est pas est-ce
que vous personnellement vous souhaitez
par exemple que françois bayroux se
présente à l'élection présidentielle ou
alors vous dites coûtait en attend de
voir
je voudrais même pas de réponse
aujourd'hui très sincèrement parce que
d'abord il faut attendre un petit peu
que tout le soufflet médiatico-politique
retombe un tout petit peu entre emmanuel
macron qu'est en train de tutoyer les
étoiles la primaire de la gauche n'est
pas fini on sait pas ce que ça va donner
nous on a on a relancé le processus du
projet présidentiel qu'on avait mis un
petit peu de côté en soutenant en
soutenant alain juppé sama fonctionne
plutôt bien
on a énormément de contributions sur ce
projet là on fait des
réunion publique sur des thèmes on en a
fait une il ya une semaine sur le thème
de la croissance des inégalités parce
que le problème qu'on a nous très très
très profondément gens nous c'est qu'on
n'accepte pas le fait que les inégalités
continuent à croître les on voit bien
que tous les projets aujourd'hui comme
si c'était un vent mondiale qui qui
souffle partout sur la planète
c'est de libérer libéralisé complètement
l'économie en faisant croître
malheureusement les inégalités et moi je
veux qu'il y ait de la place pour tous
un peu vous parliez de libéralisation
c'est un peu l'idée aussi de d'emmanuel
macron qui est créditée de 15%
d'intentions de vote selon les sondages
on a l'impression parfois que par
exemple le modem a plus intérêt à avoir
avec emmanuel macron qu'avec françois
fillon qu'en est il des troupes alors là
je vais vous dire les yvelines par
exemple pas du tout c'est parce que pour
moi emmanuel marc course est un
trompe-l'oeil son programme est encore
plus ultralibérales que celui de
françois fillon
donc quand on est centriste en tout cas
quand on est du modem du centre et du
modem
nous notre adn à la base c'est quand
même l'humain on place l'humain au
centre de tout et on est pour la
protection des précaires il ya une
histoire là dedans il y en ad n 1 on
vient des chrétiens-démocrates donc tout
ça c'est tout ça c'est lié et c'est dans
notre adn
vous voyez bien que le programme d'
emmanuel macron qui libéralise tout avec
comme conseillers autour de lui des gens
que moi je considère comme très
dangereux puisque c'étaient des comptes
d'aix conseiller d'un monsieur qui
s'appelle patrick drahi quand je vois ce
qu'il est en train de faire des affaires
s'ils font la même chose de ce qui se
passe en france moi j'ai pas envie d'y
aller donc pour moi emmanuel macron
n'est pas centriste c'est un ovni si
vous voulez un objet politique non
identifié
il n'est pas centriste on referme cette
page politique et on continue de 7,8
l'hebdo avec cette fois une
rétrospective des événements sociétaux
qui ont marqué l'année 2016 les détails
avec camille lambert 2016 une année
marquée par les manifestations contre la
loi travail dévoilé en février la
réforme du code du travail porté par
myriam el khomri a fait naître de
nombreuses critiques
les syndicats cgt et fo en tête se
mobilisent
ils seront rejoints par le mouvement
citoyen nuit debout et par les étudiants
c'est la base même du projet de loi qui
ne convient pas c'est l'esprit même de
cette loi qui vise à libéraliser un
temple un peu plus le marché du travail
qui vise à augmenter la précarité des
jeunes est donc temps l'esprit même de
cette loi on peut pas l'accepter comme
l'ensemble des secteurs aujourd'hui on
est attaqué violemment conçoit cheminots
qu'on travaille dans d'autres secteurs
et aujourd'hui le combat contre la loi
un travail c'est un peu une occasion de
fédérer un peu tous les mécontentements
qui sont en train de s'exprimer dans
tous les secteurs rochman phares comme
ailleurs et cette manifestation
aujourd'hui la en est l'expression au
terme de cinq mois de protestations la
loi travail a été adopté en juillet sans
vote à l'issue d'un troisième recours à
l'article 49-3 une année encore sous
menace terroriste le 13 juin 2016 un
couple de policiers est assassiné à
l'armé blanche à magnanville leur fils
trois ans au moment des faits est sain
et sauf
le meurtrier l'a rossi à bala
appartenaient à l'organisation
terroriste état islamique
il a été tué lors de l'assaut lancé par
le raid l'émotion était palpable
j'ai eu l'occasion d'exprimer aux
policiers notre immense tristesse
toute notre compassion dans le de leur
dire la solidarité de la république dans
toutes ses forces se rassembler je suis
extrêmement choquée puisqu'on a atteint
on a fait à tintin aux valeurs de la
république et surtout parce que je suis
extrêmement en colère je pense surtout à
cet enfant de trois ans qui se
retrouvent orphelins c'est très triste
ça pourrait arriver à n'importe qui j'ai
l'impression qu'on est plus en sécurité
ici le 31 mai les yvelines était sous
les eaux de nombreuses communes ont été
touchées par des inondations dans les
champs les récoltes ont été ravagées
les agriculteurs avaient reçu le soutien
du conseil départemental
en décembre le conseil départemental
avec la chambre d'agriculture d'île de
france a débloqué une aide de 400 mille
euros plus de 600 exploitations
céréalières vont en bénéficier cette
année 2016 c'est aussi le rapprochement
et le projet de fusion entre yvelines et
hauts-de-seine conséquence des baisses
de dotations de l'état
une fusion qui vise donc à réaliser des
économies en mutualisant leurs services
en mars les deux départements ont créé
un établissement public de coordination
interdépartementale
30 jan cette pie ix fenêtre site alios
un nouvel aménageur franciliens ses
missions ça va être de trop service des
communes en particulier et de leur
apporter toutes les compétences avec en
même temps toute la réflexion que nous
allons conduire et qui sera une
réflexion qui sera plutôt dans une
philosophie de liberté des collectivités
locales que dans celle du la
centralisation étatiste dire est
développé par grand paris aménagements
après bonnel en septembre 2015 l'accueil
des migrants dans les yvelines s'est
renforcé en 2016 plusieurs centres ont
vu le jour malgré différentes
manifestations notamment à versailles à
rocquencourt une quarantaine de migrants
sont installés sur le site de l'inria
depuis novembre suite au démantèlement
d'un camp un pari maurepas a elle aussi
accueilli une centaine de personnes en
novembre mais avec un début houleux les
élus avaient d'abord manifesté leur
opposition
je suis très en colère parce que
maurepas a déjà rempli son devoir
d'humanité pour accueillir des débits
grand l'été dernier au gymnase des
baissière et une seconde fois l'état
réquisitionne ce bâtiment en pleine
année scolaire par un accord avec la
mairie et les autorités de l'état les
migrants étaient finalement logé dans la
salle des fêtes
en novembre les yvelines accueillait au
total 400 migrants l'année 2016 a été
bruno myle in une année assez sombre
entre attentats on l'a vue là le
problème des migrants les inondations
aussi est-ce que vous êtes optimiste
pour 2010 et dit ce qu il ya de quoi
être optimiste aujourd'hui c'est un
message que vous êtes optimiste
non mais c'est un message juste moi je
vais lancer aux candidats de la
présidentielle on l'a vu les grèves les
gens sont au bord de la crise de nerfs
en ce qui concerne leur pouvoir machin
les classes moyennes se déclassent de
plus en plus il ya de plus en plus de
pauvres ne les oubliez pas le terrorisme
c'est un problème il faut vraiment que
l'europe se réveille et qu'elle met
toutes en commun que tous les pays
d'europe mettent en commun leurs
services de renseignement on l'a vu avec
ce qui s'est passé à berlin
il a quand même fallu quatre jours pour
récupérer et tué six terroristes il ya
qui a fait son attentat au marché de
noël de berlin et puis dernière chose
les migrants mondiaux l'état était un
petit peu coupable quand même cette
année parce que c'est pas en
perquisitionnant en allant contre les
élus locaux les élus du territoire qu'on
peut accueillir ces gens là m'ont dit on
en accueille 36 milles on et 66 millions
faisons le bien on leur doit ça c'est
jean son danger de mort chez eux donc on
leur doit sa voix lasse et trois petits
messages à passer aux futurs candidats
il faut pas qu'ils oublient ces gens là
merci bruno myle yens d'être venu en
plateau je rappelle que vous êtes
conseiller régional d'île de france
président du modem 78 est également
vice-présidente du coup du comité
régional du tourisme
bonne fête à vous faites à vous les
faites justement on parle avec le père
noël vert une opération solidaire mise
en place depuis de nombreuses années par
le secours populaire grâce à son armée
de père noël vert l'association collecte
tous les ans des jouets pour les
revendre lors de braderies ouverte aux
plus défavorisés
l'une d'entre elle se tenait récemment à
la verrière reportage d'anne laure
languit et patrick jacques de dixmude
ça y est le père noël est passé ici à la
verrière les cartons débordent de
poupées voitures et autres jouets en
tout genre tous sont étiquetés entre 1
et 10 euros
de quoi offrir aux enfants des familles
en difficulté un vrai noël ce sont des
jouets que nous collectons à la fois
auprès de particuliers des dons toute
l'année on colette et il ya eu aussi une
grande partie des jouets qui viennent de
la collègue de ski bus avant de les
mettre en vente le secours populaire tri
vérifie et si besoin reparler jouer bien
que les collectes se soient effectués
tout au long de l'année
la braderie propose toutefois des jouets
dernière mode à prix cassés quand vous
voyez qu'il ya des
des jouets qui sont vendus à 5 euros
alors qu'ils valent 30 ou 40 donc c'est
quand même intéressant pour tous ces
gens qui sont en grande difficulté
en une matinée la braderie a vendu pour
600 euros de jouets une somme qui
servira notamment à financer le repas du
nouvel an du secours populaire organisée
sur des péniches à paris et si vous vous
demandez encore pourquoi les pères noël
sont verts voilà la réponse au début des
années 1900 le père noël était vert et
le père noël rouge il est devenu rouge
grâce à une grande société qui s'appelle
coca cola un pied de nez à une société
de consommation qui a bien inventé le
père noël rouge mais oublié de faire
profiter tous les enfants de sa
générosité
noël c'est forcément les cadeaux mais
c'est aussi de grandes tablées à
quelques heures du réveillon les hôtes
d'un soir sont en pleine préparation
chez les commerçants comme ont pu le
constater à voisins le bretonneux
michael et demi d'euros et patrick
jacques de dixmude
le compte à rebours avant noël a débuté
chez les commerçants le rythme
s'accélère pour pouvoir répondre aux
commandes et clients chez ce caviste
implantée à voisins le bretonneux depuis
17 ans prépare les stocks en amont pour
anticiper ce dernier run mois de
septembre je rentre déjà des produits
par rapport aux fêtes de fin d'année une
petite astuce jour j c'est que les
produits selon les producteurs
augmentent leurs prix en prévision des
fêtes
on se rapproche de lui produire une
chair donc nous on prend un peu de marge
de manoeuvre
on achète en amont de façon pour
proposer des produits à des prix qui
tient davantage ne soient pas
prohibitifs
lewis qui les champagnes sont les best
seller de ces périodes de fêtes 2016
mais certains préfèrent les alcools
traditionnels j'ai pris un armagnac pour
mon père en fait c'est un fan bien faire
adéquation assez important de savoir
placer un bon vin et puis derrière sir
digestif c'est assez important à
quelques mètres dans cette boucherie les
clients sont trois fois plus nombreux
qu'en temps normal
les commandes sont passées généralement
quatre à cinq jours avant le repas du
réveillon
eh bien il vous l'avez les fêtes de noël
nous sommes que quatre et est donc je
profite de la bonne viande de ce
boucher pour pour commander pour
répondre à cette demande les débouchés
de la structure n'hésitent pas à faire
des heures supplémentaires
c'est comme des journées longues mais
même le soir quand on ferme à 19h30 on
obligé de rester veut travailler on fait
beaucoup de préparations maison beaucoup
de furets beaucoup de choses en croûte
et tout ça donc c'est fait maison c'est
très loin faire pas de répit non plus
pour les poissonniers les fêtes de noël
sont aussi un moment charnière pour le
secteur cette structure vie sinoise
réalise près de 30% de son chiffre
d'affaires annuel au mois de décembre
commence à chercher des produits genre
de coquilles saint jacques les gens
s'aiment beaucoup sur deux sur le tarif
mais sinon c'est saint jacques son lot
barre pour se réveiller en 2016 le
budget moyen pour un repas traditionnel
sur les 35 euros par convive
de quoi vous mettre l'eau à la bouche
enfin avant de vous quitter sachez que
la rédaction de tv fil 78 2 vous propose
à partir de demain soir 20h30 une
émission spéciale noël une émission que
vous pourrez également revoir le 31
décembre et le 1er janvier 2010 est une
émission pour vous souhaiter de bonnes
fêtes c'est la fin de ce s est 8 hebdo
merci de nous avoir suivi cette émission
est à retrouver en podcast sur tv fil 78
points comme bon week-end à tous joyeux
noël et bonne fête donc nouveau numéro
du 7-8 l'hebdo le 6 janvier prochain
[Musique]